foreign
something happened inside
no
did you bump into somebody or what
happened so what's going on
I'm not gonna speak to you anymore I'm a
lawyer I don't have to talk to you I'm
gonna get in the car okay I'm sorry that
she is telling you these things okay
what's your name I don't have to answer
that I'm sorry sir if I'm investigating
a crime you don't you do know what you
lie in custody
you can be until we figure it out
so
tell me what's going on listen was it an
accident or
what
I did not do anything intentionally
to Marie March
okay with her words or was it just
walking or what was it
I walked through the door I did not do
anything intentionally to Marie March
okay
then what what are they trying to say to
me then
I did not do anything intentionally to
Marie March you have a large number of
people who don't want me to win an
election against Marie March in fact
they're actually trying to rig a
convention against me where both members
of the House of delegates and she would
have you believe that I did something
which I did not I have not intentionally
done anything for three months okay
well so if I'm
not on in custody then I'm gonna go to
the call you're afraid to go now you've
got to figure it out but actually she
feels like
she needs doing anything she can't okay
what was his score
do anything
so story I'm getting from about seven
people in there is they're running
against each other they're running
against each other and he was walking by
knocked her into her intentionally
knocked her off balance in front of a
whole group of people and kept walking
as you know how you did people in high
school
you know
she wishes
well she's going to
that's what she knows me right
so yeah
right that I said I mean she's like
wearing delicate I say it's okay yeah
Cindy I have y'all had problems with you
because you're running against each
other I said
okay
ironically we're running against each
other yeah they did explain he had a
little fit with one other man and he
chewed him he yelled at him and then
when he walked past me he slammed me
everybody
saw it so literally probably 20 people
witnessed it yeah and they're all I mean
there's older gentlemen's ready to go
take a mountain back parking lots
oh absolutely I've got to he just I mean
I don't know if he's lost his mind or
what doing that in front of a group of
people but I mean I'm not gonna get
picked on
and I'm also a cedar delegate so we're
both in the general assembly and this is
it happened it's teenage I'm a lot older
than him too I'm a good 15 years older
than him I don't actually know
yes sir yes I will
how much longer uh we can go right now I
reckon I'll just go tell everybody bye
well do you apologize
thank you sorry I know it's drama how
embarrassing
we don't bring this stuff usually out of
the county so this is never going on
Jody he went after you too taking
complaints he body slammed me on his way
out yeah he slammed into me
I'm talking to Rich Anderson chairman of
the public party at Virginia and he
interrupts my conversation points
directly at me because watch out for
this one he's trying to stream and turn
you know Colonel Jody is a colonel he's
a retired colonel from the Air Force
he's a fighter I don't expect to be
treated that way
right right I'm taking out charges
for Witnesses
right
foreign
[Music]
I may text everybody
[Music]
speeches
[Music]
yes it is
all right
all right I'll see y'all
not tomorrow
gracious yes
do you have any of his information
pardon me do you have any of his
information other than his name
I just know he lives in Patrick County
he was an attorney and I said yes who
you are who cares and I said but if
there's something going on there's so we
went through that little ordeal sign oh
no ma'am
okay do you want us to take one well if
you I'll go get him yes
we'll put them up yeah okay you want
another one sure okay I'll go get it I
don't know where my husband's at here he
comes he's driving so
I'm just embarrassed this is
redness
okay
he's walking like this and then he goes
over her like he did he body slammed me
as hard as he could yep yep
all right here we're gonna follow him to
the magistrates okay so y'all need their
address dude yeah put them on the
witness
I didn't see anything yeah
yeah everybody saw it okay okay ready
let me follow you you're right here yes
ma'am right here